the Miami Heat threw every punch they
had but the Denver Nuggets are 2023 NBA
champions
this franchise has waited longer than
any other in league history to Win It
For the First Time
but here in June the Larry O'Brien
trophy is now a mile high welcome in
everybody it's game time live at the
finals presented by YouTube TV great to
have you with us here on the confetti
covered floor at ball Arena here with
NBA champions Isaiah Thomas Steve Smith
Brendan Haywood I'm Matt Weiner game
five was a grind as you would expect in
a Do or Die situation with Miami on the
floor Brendan there was nothing pretty
about this unless you're a nuggets fan
right now yeah the game wasn't pretty
but a lot of time the situation is it
isn't going to be pretty both teams know
each other well they're playing hard
they're scrapping they're getting after
everything there's a lot of pressure
there's a lot of moments we saw a lot of
missed shots tonight but at the end of
the day the Denver Nuggets were able to
make enough plays whether it was
offensively or defensively to be able to
pull out this game
well it came down to the first couple
games where the Miami Heat couldn't
Rebound with the Denver Nuggets and then
also points of the paint and then the
best player on the floor was the best
player on the floor and that was joking
so if you look at his shooting
percentage look at his rebounds look at
the way he made plays down the stretch
timely plays took advantage of the Zone
posted up against the Zone everything
was in the paint for jokic and the
nuggets and they won the grind out game
like Brendan Haywood talked about as
usual he took what was given to him he
hit 12 of his 16 shots and a closeout
opportunity jokic goes for 28 16 boards
four assists and he is the finals MVP
not only is he the finals MVP but I love
the way he's brought the big man back
and the way he's played the way he's
conducted himself
throughout this season you know it's had
an MVP season MVP of the finals even
though he didn't win MVP at a regular
season he was right there I mean he's
been fantastic the whole year Nicola
jokic and Michael Malone have been
spending a lot of time together over the
last eight seasons that's jokic's
Brothers
celebrating with Coach Malone that is
awesome what a great scene a lot of
those here tonight Denver's been waiting
a long time to celebrate again this
franchise began as an ABA team in the
1960s who came over as one of four teams
in the merger from the ABA after making
the ABA finals but never even a finals
trip in the NBA until this spring and
now an NBA championship and we'll get
into this later but a team that should
contend for years to come because their
core group is all well south of 30 years
of age but for now it is time to
celebrate the Nuggets of five game win
over the Miami Heat game as they were
Denver it was pretty obvious from the
beginning of the series was a better
team yet we always talk about the heat
culture and how hard they play and how
together they play but they ran into a
team that played just as hard that plays
justice together but they happen to have
the best player on the floor and so with
jokish making plays down the stretch
whether that was in the zone or or
whether it was surprisingly his
defensive plays as well stepping up on
screens getting his hands on balls they
were able to take over Take Miami simply
because at the end of the day the talent
won out
yeah I mean so much talent on this
roster but I think also people don't
realize so much size at every position
if you look at the Denver Nuggets from
point guard all the way to jokic's
massive Eric Gordon people don't realize
Michael Porter Jr is 6-10 and give him a
lot of credit today a double double
didn't shoot the ball particularly well
but found a way to make an impact on the
glass point to the paint for him he
struggles shooting it but he came up
with a big game with a double double
when he had 16 points and 13 rebounds
just kidding when you talk about that
size where it really shows up is in the
rebounding category you know I rebounded
Miami
57-44 using their size using their
length and you know in that fourth
quarter the defense really held Miami to
18 points and that's what showed up for
them
just 38 points in the second half from
Miami again struggled during the regular
season with offense found lightning in a
bottle in the early rounds particularly
against Milwaukee and stunning the
number one seated box but offensively
just couldn't hang with Denver in this
series yeah that's not the end of the
day we know this team they played very
well defensively and
they they scored at times but they
reverted back to who they were in the
regular season when we talked about what
happened in this series Denver started
playing real-life defense they started
paying attention to detail and I think
the size of Smitty and Isaiah were
talking about on the rebound I think it
bothered him defensively those closed
out some Aaron Gordon they look a little
bit different Michael Porter at 6 10. uh
kcp getting those passing Lanes they
were able to close out take away those
open looks and outside of game two where
Denver admittedly said we didn't come
out with the right Focus outside of that
Miami didn't have any good offensive
games in this series that's right well
consider family who played his butt off
in the series but coming into tonight's
game was 13-36 from the paint I don't
know what the numbers were tonight for
him but he struggled with Denver's Lake
whether it was jokic or Gordon or
whoever was over there yeah and and
again as we as we said at the start of
the show
Denver really had all the answers to the
test everything that Miami threw at them
they had a counter for everything that
Miami tried to do offensively and
defensively Denver had accounted for
Denver really was the best team in this
series they were the best teams
throughout the NBA this year
and nothing they did in this series
surprised us they were just steady and
consistent all series long and this
whole game proved it yeah and I will say
the mighty heat get Bama to buy on this
whole group a lot of credit I think for
bam he competed on both ends he need a
sidekick he needs to play with size you
better give him some relief because he
had to rebound he had to pass he had to
score you know they were never making
excuses but they was missing Tyler hero
uh Victor little people they just
frankly run out of gas playing those two
two playing games I think also hurt them
as well well you also saw Eric Spoelstra
struggling with who to put in when bam
wasn't on the floor who to put in uh
beside him he went to Zeller at times he
went to love at times he wasn't sure
what to do he's just not a lot of size
on that team and he mentioned Tyler hero
that's the story line tonight as well we
were under the impression that he was
available Eric holster said he was
available tonight for game five we I
guess we maybe incorrectly assumed he
would make an appearance at some point
but never did see hero in a game where
they frankly could have used some kind
of shot making yeah but it's just really
tough to put body in in game five of the
NBA Finals a closeout game but God
hasn't played in two months you're
talking about making sure that he has
his legs underneath him he's up to gang
speed caught up on the game plan
everything else and the guy just simply
had to play a lot of basketball I'm not
surprised that spolsterer didn't put him
in this type of situation especially
with the way they've gotten good minutes
out of Duncan Robinson struce and Gabe
Vincent and Kayla Martin all playoffs
so Nicole jokic with the goggles a hun
Dred mask
getting the champagne shower inside here
at ball Arena we've got much more to get
to here including guests out on the set
nobody wants to leave inside the place
is still pretty packed with the kids and
Nuggets fans and family of personnel
getting on the stage to get photo
opportunities
man get it all in tonight we haven't had
a whole team win us win a championship
on their own floor in a long time man a
long time that's been a little while
trying to think of when that was
Milwaukee
[Music]
yeah it was Milwaukee yeah after that
was probably Golden State right it might
have been
great celebration here though great
celebration Nuggets win at 94.89 it was
a disastrous start for Denver who had
four turnovers in the first two and a
half minutes of this game 10 in the
first quarter after just eight in old
game four and you were wondering if
maybe this was going to be a game two
type performance from them in terms of
the focus that Michael Malone has talked
about Denver came out a little tight
offensively and they would turn the ball
over but give him credit they didn't let
their bad offense make them fall asleep
defensively there's some teams that when
they're not doing it defensively they
have that woe is me attitude they're put
their head down and they start giving up
shots even when the shots weren't
falling even when they were turning it
over you would see a great hustle back
by guys like contavious Caldwell Polk uh
to get in on those plays on some of
those turnovers so they weren't playing
at a high efficiency level early on but
the hustle was there from the jump well
there's Nicola yokich who has done
something no player has ever done before
he led all players this postseason
points rebounds and assists and keep in
mind the Nuggets only played 20 games
because they only lost four times in the
play and see if you're a Finals MVP is
this the greatest playoff run that we've
seen in NBA history I had to go to an
MVP on this one and in terms of the
player of a player not a team that's a
player
I would have to compare this to what
Shaq did okay because sex run was
un unreal and it was it was something
that we didn't know if we would see that
type of dominance again from a center
because the game was evolving and
changing but to see the Joker do this as
a at the center position where the game
right now is so heavily weighted
for the small player and the perimeter
player to have a center come in and do
this
when you know really everything is
stacked against the big man you know
it's pretty impressive he keeps barging
into more and more exclusive clubs he's
now one of just 10 players in NBA
history with multiple regular season
MVPs and a Finals MVP on his resume and
he's 28. you know man Brendan asked a
question I would agree with Isaiah has
been some dominant performance I don't
know if we've seen anything this
efficient I mean you talk about a finals
closeout game yeah it's 12 for 16. I
mean we most big guys are getting dunks
I don't know if he got a dunk in this
series for him to be able to have this
type of touch it was guard like Zeke I
mean yeah yeah well you talked about it
you said it we go from Shaq to wilt to
Isaiah we comparing him to Littles
mediums balls in every era which is
special because he's still young and
I see more Hardware in his future Big
Time Hardware well it's hard not to he
was 12 of 16 tonight and as usual took
whatever was available to him I don't
know that he forced to shop the entire
series which if again there are folks
out there who haven't watched a ton of
Denver basketball they'll be watching
now this is who Nicola jokic is yeah and
so
this is why at the beginning of the
season and it was never anybody on our
network but when people were saying this
guy was stat padding and things of that
nature who said that I won't tell you
say who but it was a lot of people it
really infuriated me because when I
watched him play
as a big man I Marvel at what he's able
to do yeah he doesn't four shots he
takes them when he's when they're there
he'll pass up a good shot to get a great
shot there's times where he could easily
shoot a floater but he understands the
importance of getting Aaron Gordon that
live dunk yeah Aaron Gordon has to play
all this hard defense let me reward my
guy and give him a quick dunk real quick
so he feels good you know you gotta you
got to feed your dogs if you want him to
hunt jokish understands that and
offensively he's as skilled as anybody
from the post position that we've ever
seen yeah not only is a skill but he's a
great teammate yes not only is he a
great teammate he's become a great
leader and you know when you have that
leadership
good teammate and then he's the best
player then he's putting it the work
ethic again also behind it we really
laid the foundation for you know some
success for a long time and when you
look at Murray you look at Malone and
you look at yokits right they got the
coats
they got the one and they got the five
so they really have everything lined up
you know for the next couple of years
and you can kind of build around that I
mean they they got it going on here in
Denver you know I would add Isaiah there
and they have a lot of Youth yeah these
guys are still young and I also look at
it as we're going back to Jokers
to Brendan it's a good both of you guys
said it's so crazy to see a guy not need
a lot of touches right there to be this
effective even at the certain spot you
see people asking for the basketball and
rightfully so the best players but he's
able to get other guys shot make other
guys feel good and still get his 30 20
and 10. I haven't seen anything like
this and have the gravity that we talked
about during the Steph Curry
championship years where the opposing
defense has to react to wherever he is
on the floor how often did you see
during the finals some smaller heat
Defender bent over at the waist trying
to keep jokic from getting inside the
free throw line and those are the tough
things there's a lot of guys that that
want to go out there and shoot those
step back jumpers and face up that are
big men but jokic is willing to go out
there run the court hard roll roll roll
to the basket hard seal inside get big
those things matter Little Things become
big things if you want to be a champion
you have to be completed especially as a
big and you still have to be able to
dominate in that I know we love the
threes the three-point error but when
you can go ahead and dominate inside the
inside that charge circle area that
means something I don't think big men
get any more pleasure
out of
disrespecting a little man for sure
trying to guard him for sure I mean
because it's disrespectful for a small
man to try to guard a big in the paint
and then when a big actually lets that
small guy know not only am I bigger than
you but you in my area you're in my zone
and I'm gonna punish you and we saw
jokic do that this whole series every
time he was matched up with a smaller
person manager said I'm sure they'll
show pictures of that smaller guy like
trying to hold your guitar with all that
weight leaning on him right I don't
think the league now is going to
continue to do that with him now they
may do it with other Sinners but with
jokic he's making you pay it's important
when you're when your bigs know how to
play Big there's some guys that are 7-1
that never go inside yeah it's important
when your bigs know how to play Big
because when they switch to pick and
roll yeah you can throw it inside
Dominate and then when they start double
and triple teaming you you spray to the
perimeter and then you get those easy
threes first time